AKIL WORD-DANIELS:
Light's all around us.
So you see how have
lights in LED form,
you have lights shining
from the ceiling,
you have lights
coming from the sun.
A laser's just the
purest form of light.
It's just something
majestic about a laser that
just drives me to
it and makes me
want to create them, and use
them, and just play around
with them.
My name is Akil
Word-Daniels, and I'm
an electrical
engineering graduate
student working on my Ph.D.
Not to mention, these are
pretty robust actually.
These samples came
out very good.
In my opinion,
electrical engineering
is one of the broadest fields
that you could possibly do.
You can go to the extreme
sides of computer science
and work on the
toughest algorithms --
maybe for error correction
and quantum computing --
or you could do optical
coherence tomography for health
sensing, or you can go all
the way to the physics side
and look at single spins of
electrons using magnets to work
with quantum information.
CLAIRE GMACHL: Do
you know why it's not
like a smooth function?
AKIL WORD-DANIELS:
So that, I think,
is because the way functions
themselves also overlap other --
CLAIRE GMACHL: Good.
AKIL WORD-DANIELS:
-- others varies as well.
And I think that's where some
of these bumps are coming from.
I specifically work with
quantum cascade lasers.
What my job is, is to make sure
that I could either optimize
how quantum cascade laser
works or maybe even transfer it
into a new material system.
Like if you could put
a quantum cascade laser
into like a silicon
system -- something
that we use an all
microelectronics -- then
you could get cheap,
affordable systems that you
can use on your cell phone.
Academics are only
half the story.
I mean, there's
only so much time
that you can put into your
research in the science.
But in order to be a
well-rounded person,
you have to get
away from the lab.
You have to go out and get
involved in different student
groups.
You have to get out,
exercise your body.
It's important that you
exercise things other than just
your scientific mindset.
I wanna say you should get out,
play soccer, get out, become
part of organizations,
lead organizations.
My favorite thing to do,
actually, in my off time,
by far, is softball.
I used to play
baseball in college.
And so every summer we
have a softball league
where the departments
go against each other.
And we bring in things like the
treasury department or maybe
the facilities, and we all
have these massive
free-for-alls in softball.
And it's just so much
bonding and laughing and just
having a whole bunch of fun
hitting baseballs and softballs
and just playing a
whole bunch of sports.
After Princeton, by far, I want
to be an advocate for science --
specifically for
science policies,
how they are implemented, and
basically influence communities
that you have a non-ideal
environment for science
education.
I don't feel like science
is really promoted enough
and I feel like,
even as researchers,
sometimes we don't go out and
bring people into the science
community, as well.
Every day, I wake up and
I try to think about,
how can I improve
my communities?
It's something that's a
deep-seated passion for me.
And my research training here is
just setting me up for success
in that sense.
In my opinion,
scientific research --
the fundamentals
of it -- I think is
a gateway on solving all of
the problems in the world.
[MUSIC PLAYING]